any suggestions I'll make you alive you
don't know what was your question again
booth hey everybody its charlie this is
gonna be my video for all the missing
characters from infinity war not
avengers for this is just infinity war
remember two parts story even though the
title for Avengers 4 is gonna be
something different surprisingly the
writers the directors the producers
explain where most of these characters
were during the course of the movie so
just careful for spoilers if you have
not seen infinity war yet we'll be
talking about really specific stuff that
was not in the movie if you're finding
me for the first time there's gonna be a
whole bunch of infinity war Avengers for
Captain Marvel ant-man of the wasp
Deadpool stuff dropping really soon be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there is that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
that's still going on I'll explain that
at the end of the video starting with
number 10 we'll just do this as a top 10
list so Hawkeye probably one of the
biggest phase 1 Avengers that just had
no presence at all during infinity war
got two brief shoutouts during the movie
once when they were explaining what
happened post-civil war after Captain
America broke everybody out of the raft
then during the post-credits scene where
Nick Fury and Maria hill gave him a
shout-out they were gonna activate
Barton before everything went crazy
simple explanation is is that after
Captain America broke them out of the
raft
Hawkeye went on the run their families
including ant-man's family like his
little daughter just couldn't handle it
so they cut deals with general Ross
who's Secretary of State so they went
under house arrest you kind of saw them
address that at the beginning of the
first ant-man trailer so Hawkeye as of
right now during infinity war post
finger snap is still chilling on his
farm now what happened to his family
during that finger snap remains to be
seen because we all have theories about
also you know including my number 9
ant-man and the wasp where were they
that portions of their family or like
people really important to them will get
turned to ash at the end of ant-man and
the wasp and that'll provide the lead
into Avengers 4 so I'm not expecting to
see Hawkeye during the ant-man in the
wasp post-credit scene we might just
catch up with him at the beginning of
Avengers 4 with him dealing with the
loss of his family but like I said
number 9 ant-man the wasp I've already
talked about this during my trailer
video a little bit they just explained
that he was under house arrest during
infinity war the wasp like this is all
taking
place before the events of infinity war
so you have to imagine that while this
is all going down the finger-snap
they're probably inside the quantum
realm being protected from the effects
of the Infinity Gauntlet so they don't
get turned to ash because we know
they're confirmed big characters during
Avengers 4 number 8 Captain Marvel where
she during infinity war I think we kind
of explained this during my post credits
scene video she's got that galactic
pager but simplest explanation is that
Captain Marvel is still in deep space
dealing with Kree and Skrulls so bigger
war going on in outer space than had
previously been going on on planet Earth
but now that's all changed because
Thanos has the gauntlet so in comes
Captain Marvel via 90s souped up space
pager but number 7 this is a big one
Adam warlock nowhere to be found during
the movie but a huge part of comic book
Infinity Gauntlet so people are like
where is he is he gonna show up during
Avengers 4 James Gunn was actually he's
been really cool about this explaining
where some of the guardians characters
that were missing were a long time ago
way before they ever started marketing
infinity war after we got that guardians
to post-credits scene and everyone
started freaking out oh my god is he
gonna have the soul gem is it in his
special birthday per their the cocoon
that he comes out of in the comic books
I don't remember who started talking
about it but eventually James Gunn did
come out and confirm that there was
going to be no Adam warlock during
infinity war or Avengers 4 and then more
recently at the premiere the writers of
infinity war said that the reason why
they didn't want to include him as a
character is is because it would have
required too much back bending at the
beginning of the film to explain who he
was what his powers are in what his
relationship with Thanos is and
currently he has no relationship with
him he's being grown in his cocoon as a
weapon to fight the Guardians that's the
whole reason why she decided to make
this perfect being so if you wonder why
we get to Avengers 4 and you don't see
out of warlock that's why the first time
we're supposed to see him as of right
now like this could change a little bit
but is guardians 3 now James Gunn did
come out and say he's like I didn't
confirm that he was gonna show up during
guardians 3 but that's the whole idea is
that guardians 3 is gonna be the last
movie with the current roster of
guardians pending Gamora status because
we don't know what's gonna happen to her
we all believe that Peter quill is gonna
come back like these ash 2 people will
come back at some point so most of this
go
Dean's roster will be made whole they'll
have one final ride and then they'll
cycle the roster we won't learn a lot
about that till next year Kevin Feige is
like yeah we're not gonna make a whole
bunch of phase four announcements this
year because of infinity war but we
don't want to give away any spoilers for
Avengers four number six another big
question where was Valkyrie Korg
and meek on that as guardianship what
about all the as guardians to if Asgard
isn't a place it's a people in Thor
power comes from his people if all those
people died that how does Thor still
have his power so like Tessa Thompson
the actress that plays Valkyrie was
making all kinds of jokes this is me
during infinity war like this little
lamb being carried around by Sebastian
Stan Kevin Feige the writers the
producers pretty much every high-level
person associated with infinity war said
that Valkyrie Korg and meek in about
half of the Asgardians made it off in
escape pods before Theo showed up and
killed the rest of those people number
five was crackling James Gunn was
talking about him a lot the other day on
Twitter people were like where the hell
is he he was last seen on the
guardianship so James Gunn just said
that he was doing special stuff for the
Guardians he would be an important
character when we come back with the
guardians in vol 3
soaked Raglan is fine he just went off
somewhere else to do separate mission in
the Guardians new ship is actually named
the Benatar after a pat benatar
but number four the Grandmaster the
other elders of the universe the
collector was the only one that actually
appeared in the movie and it was
posthumously because Thanos killed him
off screen before the Guardians made it
to nowhere even though he showed up on
screen it was a trick of the reality gem
you could take those Darryl team shorts
as cannon but really the idea is the
Grandmaster is alive somewhere else in
disgrace in exile basically the people
revolted he was kicked off the car so
he's alive out there somewhere so are
the other elders of the universe that we
have not seen yet in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and they're a lot
like you have the gardener who is the
person that arguably created Groot
although he is from a race of people the
gardener like recently in the comics
they had this really cool twist between
the gardener and Groot but there's the
possessor the runner the stranger the
trader that I mean there's basically
countless numbers of elders of the
universe that they get surfaced during
the other Guardians films or these other
space-based films if they pop up they'll
probably be just as weird and just
cool as Benicio del Toro in what Jeff
Goldblum did with his Grandmaster
character but number three still owns
Ravagers if you remember he played
Starhawk during guardians volume two
there's like the whole ravager force he
was basically the leader of all of the
Ravagers they're pretty big fleet they
were nowhere to be found James Gunn did
tease after volume two that they would
pop up maybe not necessarily in their
own film but in someone else's because
yondu and star Hawks team was meant to
be the original Guardians team from the
comics now the team that Peter quill put
together only came after annihilation
conquest it was sort of like a soft
reboot for the Guardians franchise like
here's guardians of the galaxy but it's
a brand new team with a new roster so og
Guardians will probably come back in one
of these other space-based movies that
they're developing that are be like a
spin-off of the Guardians franchise
maybe they'll pop up during guardians
volume three but number two another big
question that I got where are the other
living Celestials in number one also add
this in here the greater cosmic entities
like The Living Tribunal eternity
Chronos master Order Lord chaos
obviously we don't have Galactus yet but
he would qualify as one of the
Celestials and as far as we know ego the
Living Planet was killed by Peter at the
end of guardians vol 2 so the big
explainer for all these greater cosmic
forces like including the watchers to
like you know what are they doing
because we know they exist because of
stanley's post-credit scene during
guardians to is is that the writers of
infinity war explained that Thanos had a
limited time table to collect all the
gems and use them to erase half of all
life in the universe because cosmic
forces had not yet become aware of what
he was doing
so they specifically gave a shout out to
cosmic forces talking about some of
these greater more powerful beings
particularly the Celestials anybody that
would be powerful enough to take down
Thanos wielding Infinity stones but for
those of you asking about Living
Tribunal because they got a shout out
during Doctor Strange the staff of the
Living Tribunal you can't make a staff
of the Living Tribunal if a Living
Tribunal isn't a thing that exists in
the universe so that's out there
somewhere but I will start doing more
Avengers 4 videos soon so leave all your
requests in the comments below but there
is a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway I'll just name a giveaway
winner when I post new Marvel that will
be tomorrow don't worry they'll be
plenty
of Marvel step posting in the next
couple of weeks remember a man of the
wasp and Deadpool Captain Marvel and
Avengers for stuff so click here for my
soul gem video and click here for all my
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]